Pat forty yahoo sports national college
columnist covering college football as
we run through the weekend let me start
with Ohio State Penn State Pat your
takeaway from this game was what another
second straight death-defying comeback
by Ohio State that was Adin and embedded
by Penn State Penn State hadn't been
able to finish against Ohio State
they've played two great games really
three great games in a row against him
but the last two they've given away late
leads and then you know the whole thing
it was a heck of a game and then the
fourth and five called by James Franklin
and his staff was just such a colossal
buzzkill you know you're heading towards
this really climactic exciting ending
and you run that play in that situation
and everyone's like what the hell is
that yeah my problem with it is I have
to have my best if I can put the ball in
the hands of my best player then I want
him to have it and I want to trace
McSorely to have it win or lose at least
I have it in his hands and I know they
saw something with the defense or they
thought they were gonna you know catch
them off guard here I get it i I just I
still want my best player to have his
hands on the ball absolutely especially
when your best player can either run it
or throw it I mean he's been phenomenal
all night he was you know we've him for
175 yards he made big throws they they
couldn't stop him and to take it out of
his hands in that moment was was pretty
shocking and especially after timeout
timeout timeout and it was just seemed
like a classic how smart themselves
situation I know you posed the question
about Notre Dame going undefeated
looking at their schedule do you think
they'll go undefeated
I would say no just because well they're
a good team I don't think they are a
great team I don't think they're a team
without weakness and usually those teams
find a spot somewhere along the line to
trip up you know and maybe it's at
Virginia Tech this Saturday but Junya
Tech starting quarterback is out with a
broken leg maybe it's at the end against
USC you know maybe it's somewhere in
between Syracuse in Yankee Stadium could
turn out to be a tricky game but you
know my guess is they'd probably end up
with at least one loss but if you want
to look at it right now and project
they're gonna be favorite you would
think and ever get yeah it feels like
they'll slip up someplace they're you
know we're still not sure what we have
with Virginia Tech Syracuse Syracuse is
fun USC I don't know what to expect from
USC I mean they they allowed Arizona to
come back and nearly lost that game yeah
how would you handicap USC right now
major question marks
you know I young in some key places not
very well coached I don't think not
overly tough and physical not not very
impressed with them at this juncture now
clay held the scheme's if they've done
one thing over the last few years
they've gotten better as the seasons
gone along but five games in I'm
underwhelmed by USC we had the situation
this past week where Trevor Lawrence was
announced he was gonna be the starter so
the Clemson quarterback gets the call
over Kelly Bryant who was a decorated
starter won 16 of his 18 starred senior
now all of a sudden the incoming
freshman five-star recruit he gets the
start gets injured against Syracuse as
any does anybody know where Kelly Bryant
is right now he's from Piedmont South
Carolina which is like 25 miles from the
Clemson campus so I would not be
surprised if Clemson dispatched several
staffers to carry him on a sedan all the
way to campus but I you know I don't
know whether he's interested in coming
back I don't know whether devil wants
him when the question came up after the
game he really didn't seem interested in
it and I can understand that it's like
look we almost lost
and one of the reasons why is because
this guy left the team I wanted to talk
about the team he has right now so I
that situation still up in the air it
would be a difficult return but I don't
think it's an impossible return but if
you're looking at it from Clemson
standpoint say okay chase price was good
enough to get us through
we're playing wait for us next weekend
we think we can win that one with chase
Brice then we've got a bye week if
Trevor Lawrence you know if the injury
had more severe than it looked he should
be back after that and we can make make
a go of it it's not gonna pad 40 from
Yahoo Sports but we're also seeing this
trend here at where you really get a
couple of years to prove yourself in
college football and even then that
might not be enough because everybody's
bringing in another five star recruit
these kids are ready to go as soon as
they hit campus they're enrolling early
in some cases here and it feels like you
know Trevor Lawrence when he gets to be
a junior is gonna be facing somebody
who's a freshman coming in and probably
challenging him for his job yeah it's
pretty amazing I mean it
quarterbacks I think are ready earlier
and yeah there's more of them especially
in that position that will come in early
and be there for spring practice and
give themselves a chance to play right
away certainly the best of them want to
play as freshmen they don't want to
redshirt because they're like thinking
you know hey three years and I'm going
throw baby so you know the timetable is
just different now and quarterbacks are
they get so much more coaching before
college - with the quarterback camps and
individual instructors and that sort of
thing I just think there's a lot of them
that are a lot more ready early than
there used to be I was also watching the
Louisville game against Florida State
and I'm thinking okay and I actually
kept it on even though I thought well
you know Louisville is just gonna run
out the clock and and maybe Florida
State gets the ball back with less than
a minute to go and you know let's see if
they can go the entire field or whatever
they need to do to tie the game or maybe
win it and then all of a sudden Bobby
Petrino offensive genius at Louisville
says let's throw the ball and and now
your quarterbacks last name is Pass
do you think that he thought it was an
instruction
like Jomon pass and then quarterback
thought he meant pass instead of he was
calling him over
Juwan pass okay what do you think that's
the best explanation I've heard because
the other explanations make any sense it
was a just a catastrophic Allah bad call
I mean between that and between what
James Franklin did and Frank white right
decision yesterday is like oh my gosh
these coaches have lost their minds at
the end of games but Petrino not many
people have had a worse month than
Petrino his team is terrible
fans have kind of gotten tired of his
act Lamar Jackson's not there anymore
they cannot score which was this thing
they can't move the ball they can't
score and then you blow one of the few
games you're probably gonna have a
chance to win and it's solely on you in
that decision I mean just made no sense
whatsoever with his name maybe past but
he doesn't do it terribly well and that
showed it right then and there I mean
threw it directly into the chest of a
Florida State guy and they win the game
directly off of that do they have a
backup quarterback named take a knee
[Laughter]
take a knee in there okay give me three
games this weekend to keep an eye on
okay some pretty lights late I will say
but start with Red River shootout
Oklahoma and Texas Texas has bounced
back after that dismal loss to begin
with they look pretty good and they
played Oklahoma pretty tough in that
series lately then you would go LSU at
Florida
unless you've been one of the better
surprises so far adores wrong a lot of
people thought that he'd be playing his
way onto the hot seat by now and maybe
he's the coach of the year instead but
it's tough game and the swamp Dan Mullen
has Florida playing better and then I'd
say a Notre Dame at Virginia Tech the
Ian book and keep that thing rolling now
you did say the Red River shootout not
it's not known as the shootout is that
because you can't say Red River Rivalry
it's because I guess III have an
aversion to cleansing names like that
for reasons that don't really strike me
as compelling read with a Weibull we
yeah got a problem with them yeah
no no elmer fudd disease here I just
don't like the Maine Red River Rivalry
Thank You Pat it's good to catch up with
you
my pleasure Dan that's level weekend all
righty Pat 40 Yahoo Sports national
college football columnist there for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]